ASSEMBLY INSURANCE COMMITTEE
WERE WAITING FOR TWO MORE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM WE HAVE ONE
BILL. TO PRESENT THAT WILL BE
PRESENTED. DO WE EXPECT TO HAVE
SPEAKERS ADDRESSING THIS WE
WOULD HAVE TO PERSONALLY UPON
INVITATION WHY. DON'T I PRESENT
TO A SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. THE LEVEL
OF KERR I'LL TRY NOT TO. IF YOU
MISTER FRAZIER. OKAY. THE
CEMENT AND YEAH OUR INTEREST
YES SIR. MORE. FRAZIER. GRAYSON
VOEPEL. THIS YEAR. WE HAVE NOT
SO WE HAVE A QUORUM WE DO HAVE
A ONE BILL A BILL FOR US MR
DAILY. THANK YOU MISTER MAZEN
MEMBERS THIS BILL CONTAINS
THREE PROVISIONS TO SUPPORT
HOMEOWNERS IN THIS INSURANCE
MARKET THIS A PRO CONSUMER
BILL. INCREASES THE LIMITS FOR
HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE CLAIM
HANDLE BY THE CALIFORNIAN
CHURNS GUARANTEE ASSOCIATION.
IT ALSO INCREASES THE NUMBER OF
POLICIES A QUALIFY FOR THE
INSURER RIGHT OUT CREDITS IN
THE FAIR PLAN. AND LASTLY IT
INCREASESTHE MINIMUM NOTICE
PERIOD FOR A NON RENEWAL OF A
HOMEOWNER'S INSURANCE POLICY
FROM FORTY FIVE DAYS TO SEVENTY
FIVE DAYS. THESE CHANGES
PROVIDE TANGIBLE NEAR TERM
BENEFITS TO HOMEOWNERS AND WHAT
FOR MANY HAS BECOME A DIFFICULT
INSURANCE MARKETS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS DALY ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
SUPPORT. WILL MOVE TO ANY
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION ANY. ANYBODY WANT TO
JUST SAY THEY'RE OPPOSED SEEING
NONE WILL COME BACK I KNOW THAT
WE DID HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THERE ANY COMMENTS BY.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE BY TH. THE WE ARE
ALREADY THE BILL HAS ALREADY
BEEN MOVED I THINK IT IS THAT
WAS THAT MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE OF
THAT. THE MADE THE MOTION AND
WHO WAS THE SECOND. OKAY YEAH.
AS MR CHEN SO WITH THAT WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND A PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTEEN ARE THE MOTION AS WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN.
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES AYE
MAYES AYE BERMAN. BIGELOW.
CALDERON HI CALDERON AYE CHAN.
HI CAN I TO. COOLEY AYE COOLEY
AYE COOPER COOPER I FRAZIER
FRAZIER I GIPSON GIPSON I
GRAYSON. I'M LONGER YEAH I'M
LONGER. I THIRTIES LOOK I
RECEIVED ALL DAY. ELEVEN TO
ZERO MR BERMAN VOTES THANK YOU
MISTER THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN.
WE ARE ADJOURNED. TOO LATE OKAY.
WE HAVE A VOTE ON THE FLOOR WE
GET FROM HERE. IF YOU PERFECT
MONNING RECORD ENDING IN YEAH